want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only bruce lipton
the problem with the concept of power of
the power positive thinking is people
just think oh well if i just have
positive thoughts then my life should be
affected and and this is why positive
thinking has a real bad rap in the
public and the reason is this having a
positive thought does not in any way
necessitate that those positive thoughts
actually manifest themselves and there's
a piece that was left out and if you
don't understand the piece then you're
shouting into the wind with your
positive thoughts nothing's going to
happen and the fact is this
when you're having positive thoughts
you're using your mind
the new biology reveals that the
invisible forces
that collectively we refer to as mind
that these form a field which shape
biology
well here's what's important yes the
mind influences biology but there are
two parts to the mind that are
completely different than one another
yet they work together we confuse them
we tie them together and yet they
represent two entities working in two
different fashions there's the conscious
mind and what is called the subconscious
mind
now here's what it's very important
people have to know this okay and here's
what it is
the conscious mind is our creative mind
that is connected to our personal
identity and our spiritual selves that's
that makes us all unique our each of us
has our own personal conscious mind but
what becomes very significant is this is
the subconscious mind
is equivalent to a tape player it's
exactly what it is it records
experiences and then plays them back
and and so now let's take a look and say
well wait there's a thinking mind
and then there's a tape player mind and
what's different about them is very
profound so let's talk about two
fundamental differences first
the
tape player the subconscious mind
as an information processor as the
equivalent of a computer
is a million times more powerful on an
information processor than it's a
conscious mind
so when you look at the power between
the conscious and subconscious
subconscious a million times more
powerful
number two
on a date by day basis
the subconscious mind runs our biology
about 95 to 99 of the time
so while you're having all these
wonderful thoughts
that's not the conscience the conscious
mind is not running the show it's a
subconscious mind
then it comes the issue is well the
subconscious mind got programs in it yes
and the and the subconscious mind is not
evil or good the subconscious mind is a
tape player as much as you can say okay
here here's a tape player it's good or
bad it's not the tape player is not good
or bad
the programs can be good and the
programs can be bad so blaming the
subconscious mind as a negative thing is
that's the first mistake it's a tape
player
the programs that we got that's the
source of the problems that most of us
face
and
these programs could limit our abilities
and take away our powers which
essentially they do
now the relevance about positive
thinking is this
positive thinking is a creative thought
that comes from the conscious mind
okay so i sit here and i'm going to have
all these wonderful thoughts i'm going
to close my eyes and visualize all these
wonderful things
now stop and go back to the to the
mechanical character of it a
i'm having these thoughts with a little
tiny processor called the conscious mind
and i'm competing with the programs that
are in the subconscious mind
so if i have a thought for
uh being being healthy or being in a
good
relationship and i'm doing positive
thinking
and at the same time i've acquired
programs in my development that said
you're not as healthy as you think you
are and you you're not that good a
person to have those kind of
relationships then look i'm now pitting
my positive thoughts against my programs
and and they're in their opposite
but this one works on a little tiny
processor and this processor is a
million times more powerful so right
away it's like who's going to win in
that challenge the answer of course the
subconscious is going to win okay but
here comes the other part
while i can try to maintain positive
thoughts in my life using my conscious
mind this conscious mind only operates
less than five percent of the day
that says 95 or more of the day i'm
operating from the other belief system
the point is do the math
how powerful are positive thoughts and
the answer is
unless the subconscious has the same
programs and agreement
as the conscious mind
power of positive thinking will not work
it will not work because you're
competing against a much more powerful
processor when i finally started to
realize a very simple truth it was like
an old spiritual word but i now
understand the biological connotation of
it that we were made in the image of the
environment
and that so we are complements to the
environment
and yet what we have done is without
being aware that our biology is
dependent on the environment that we
have systematically undermined destroyed
mother nature
and gaia and in the process now we're
finding
we are threatened with our own
extinction and the fact is well we
didn't know what we were doing but the
question is uh uh will gaia allow us to
come back and he answers absolutely
because just as much as a person can
come back from the edge of death with
something called a spontaneous remission
even though science has already
recognized we are facing our extinction
so we could say that we're a terminal
patient
humanity is a dermal patient
the concept of changing our belief
system
will allow the garden to come right back
to fullness again so we are in a
learning stage to
remove ourselves from the beliefs our
current civilization which undermine not
just the humans but the environment that
that we're in and the problem is
we were created as a complement to a
certain environment
since we destroying or are destroying
that environment then we are no longer
complements to an environment then we
don't fit by definition and that is why
scientists recognize we are facing our
extinction so um
i like to apologize to nature
saying geez i'm really sorry we didn't
get it but we're learning and more and
more people especially the younger
people very importantly are recognizing
you cannot destroy this environment and
survive and that we must pull together
and honor gaia the mother of us all
because by returning our love back to
gaia gaio will give us back the love and
the life that we that we can have on
this planet okay i have a spiritual part
and i have this physical part
and i asked a simple question i said
why have a body
why not just be the spirit
and then
this is when i found out i had jewish
comedian cells
i asked a question of myself
why have a body why not just be a spirit
and 50 trillion cells in my body
welled up with an answer and i said the
answer what was i saying i asked a
question the answer came back in the
form of a question that's where the
jewish comedian guy came in again i
asked why have both a spirit in a body
and the cells answered with this
quote
bruce
if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden i said oh my god
that was the most profound thing in the
entire world i said why
because this is like a virtual reality
suit i can see with these eyes
i could smell i can taste i can hear
and i go so why is it relevant well as i
said the question came out if you're
spirit only
and sad vegeta and i are in the spirit
world and we're saying love is such a
beautiful thing it's the harmony and the
connection and everything i said yeah
but what does love feel like
you know
as a spirit how to act do i know it's
i say oh you have to have the chemistry
of the body and a nervous system
that translates the chemistry into
sensation sensation is not chemistry
it's electromagnetic vibration it's a
broadcast
and i say so why is it relevant so we
had one little part and i go what
we think our thoughts are in our head
and so we put wires on our head called
the electroencephalograph and i can read
your brain activity i go yeah inside
your head you've got all this
consciousness going on and then i go you
know there's a new technology reads
brain activity as well it's not electro
encephalograph eeg
it's called magneto encephalograph m-e-g
and i go so what's the difference they
both read consciousness i go yeah what's
the difference
magneto encephalograph the probe is out
here it doesn't even touch your head
stop
i say why
you're reading my thoughts out here
and all of a sudden it's like my
thoughts are not contained in my head
no
they're broadcast back to the field
i go i can read your thoughts from out
here
so whatever you're thinking positive or
negative or i can do this i can't do
that so it's not staying in here it's
going out into the world in the universe
around us
and then i say so what's the relevance
there's something called resonance when
two things are in vibration if one
vibrates the other one will vibrate
okay and if they're not in harmony one
vibe breaks and the other doesn't do
anything so i say so what does it mean
oh my god this is so
changed life stuff i go
my thoughts are vibration that go out
into the energy field which is quantum
physics i go so what
i say
my thought will only vibrate and
resonate with something that matches the
thought
if i send out a thought of love
only
elements that are in love that vibrate
in love will respond to my thought
because our we're in harmony we're in
resonance
if i send out a thought of fear negative
and scared i can't do this and i'm
afraid
i said what do you think is going to
vibrate i said love is not going to
vibrate
only things that you would be afraid of
things you would be you know have fear
over
they'll vibrate and i say so
put it all together
oh my god
we're creators
and we come in to this body to create
and that what we create and what we
experience is not kept in us
our mind translates it into
electromagnetic vibrations that go back
to the field
and that integrates with our spiritual
vibration because they're the two in
resonance i'm in resonant with the
spirit and the spirit is in resonance
with the body why we're using the same
vibration so our lives make a difference
that we live here and i say what first
of all we're creators we're very
powerful
i go until
a creator is programmed not to be
powerful
and then that creator by programming
will say okay i'm not powerful and give
up our power
and we have been systematically
programmed to question who and what we
are
when the fact is we came here as
creators
i go why did we come here for the
creation and i go because we get a
feedback that goes back to the source
that says what do you want and you come
here and try and create it and when you
find that love and when you find that
harmony you start to realize you're
glowing what you're glowing your energy
vibration of love is going back to the
universe to to resonate with you and
make you a stronger love
vibration i asked a question to the
universe which then my cells answered i
asked a question when i just realized
and owned i exist as a
field energy a spirit whatever you want
to call it as information in the field
and i also exist as a body
my first question that came up in my
head was then why have both why have a
spirit and a body why not just be the
spirit
and my cells
came up with this chorus that i just
blasted my head and it was kind of funny
because i think they have jewish
heritage cells because i asked them a
question and they responded in a
question
i asked why have both
and all of a sudden it welled up and the
answer came and said
bruce
if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden i said oh my god
it's the biology which is all the
receptor devices that translate my
environment into sensation which are
then translated by the nervous system
into fields and and vibrational patterns
which are then sent back to my source
and i realized at that moment i said
my god we're here to experience this
place to touch it and smell it watch
sunsets and feel love and and and eat
wonderful food and have all this and i
thought wow and then all of a sudden it
says yeah but
it's not just receiving information
when you have a body you can be creative
we can come to this planet and manifest
creativity
and we do this we step into a virtual
reality suit called the body i step into
the suit as a spirit
it communicates with me via just the
same way the mars rover is communicating
with nasa and i get to experience this
planet
beautiful part about it is of course i'm
going off on all this stuff and it's
like well what the heck is that source
that you're that's being read well the
first thing is this it's not physical
the belief that genes turn on and off is
taking power away from the individual
because if the genes were turning on and
off and i did not control them
then by definition i am a victim of
which genes did i get from my family did
cancer genes come in
heart disease genes or diabetes and now
we recognize that in regard to disease
genes are responsible for less than 10
percent of disease in fact there are
indications that genes are only
responsible for one percent of disease
so all of a sudden it says well wait we
used to think genes cause disease but if
only a small percent of disease is
controlled by genes and where is the
disease coming from that is affecting
the world the answer is now we know from
epigenetics consciousness
lifestyle belief systems these are the
ultimate controls of the gene
we know that if you've got a cancer gene
and that's what you believe then you
think i'm going to get the cancer and
then you get a cancer and you say the
genes did it and now we know no that
there is no cancer gene there is not one
gene that causes cancer
genes are correlated with cancer meaning
if your life is not in harmony and you
have one of these genes you can activate
a cancer
50 percent of the women that have the
same brca1 gene never get the cancer the
point is very important having the gene
doesn't mean you get cancer but having
the gene and not living in harmony not
living in a healthy lifestyle that
causes the cancer
and so we have to help people
take them from the belief i'm a victim
and give them the science that no your
consciousness
is creating this life experience in here
your consciousness is controlling your
genes you want to change the world we
don't have to physically go out and
physically change the world first first
we have to change our belief about the
world our belief of who we are in the
world we're not victims but we've been
programmed to believe we're frail
vulnerable that we're victims of the
world the fact is no we are the most
powerful beings and entities on this
planet
we want to get out of the box
think out of the box and that will
change all of it what you we would see
from a new understanding of evolution
which is a great extension beyond the
darwinian belief belief which is quite
limiting okay and quite troublesome in
fact uh because just think about what
the principle darwinian belief is uh
that evolution is based on a struggle
for survival with a competition for
fitness so that says oh my god then our
world is we're all out there in a
dog-eat-dog rat race trying to survive
because if you stop running the person
behind you is going to run over you so
if that's your way of life then every
day by definition you are living in a
stress hormone
body because of all the fears that we
that we have and yet evolution says no
evolution is based on community and
cooperation a body has 50 trillion
citizens they live in harmony with each
other and it turns out that
every human being we're beginning to
find out is like a cell
in a larger community called humanity so
in biological terms the organism that's
evolving on the planet is not the human
being we already did that the organism
that's evolving is the super organism
called human civilization and right now
humans are fighting each other and
killing each other and if i say well
what would that look like inside the
body if the cells fight each other and
kill each other and i say oh well that's
called autoimmune disease
and and autoimmune disease can kill you
from the inside that's on the increase
isn't it oh absolutely because the
because our biological lives are
complements to the environment the more
stress and more
violence on the outside the more that's
taken inside in biology and converted to
disruption and disharmony of your own
cellular internal community if you can
create a honeymoon for yourself while
you're in love and everyone started to
create a honeymoon for themselves then
all of a sudden the concept of war and
violence would disappear because if
everybody's in love and everybody's in
harmony and everybody's so excited by
being here
then the competition and violence that
we live by because of today's beliefs
would disappear so as you understand the
terms quantum physics and quantum
mechanics or newtonian physics and
newtonian mechanics what you see is that
physics and mechanics are synonyms so
physics really means the mechanisms by
which the universe operates and the new
physics quantum physics was something
that i really wasn't into nor were any
of my colleagues in the medical school
we were all trained in newtonian physics
and the difference between the two is
very profound newtonian physics says
the world that we live in the universe
we live in is a machine made out of
mechanical parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces
change the pieces change the operation
that's the basis of medicine we look at
a human body it's a machine made out of
physical parts when it's not working
right change the parts by buying
chemicals and drugs
and that's the way that conventional
medicine operates
when i started to read the quantum
physics i realized oh my goodness
the whole foundation of the universe is
not based on a mechanical physical
universe it's based on the invisible
energy called the field so let's say if
i hold a magnet right here in front of
you you can see the magnet but what you
can't see is the invisible magnetic
field and so what it says is well we are
physical things in our world like
physical bodies we're immersed in fields
electro
magnetic fields magnetic fields itself
all kinds of fields like telephone cell
phone fields television fields radio
fields whole ranges
what is the difference between the
newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you won't understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by albert
einstein and it's simple it goes
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
in other words in the world of invisible
things fields and particles matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sixth state
that's the physical expression and the
answer is well to understand that don't
look at the body you have to understand
the invisible forces in the field
and it's fun because if you think about
when when of course when you were young
at some point you must have had like
iron filings and sprinkled it around a
magnet and all of a sudden you saw the
iron filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics
would look at this pattern
and try to explain how come all the iron
filings fell in this pattern without
recognizing that the field exists in
other words can you explain why the iron
filings have the shape if you don't
recognize the magnetic field the answer
is absolutely not
what's the nature of it
the body and its cells are like iron
filings medicine is trying to understand
the nature of the body by looking at the
iron filings and quantum physics says if
you don't understand that invisible
field you can't understand what's
happening in the body the cells in your
body are not connected to the outer
environment but they have to adjust
themselves to that outer environment and
the relevance about that well then how
they know what to do because
something has to tell them what the heck
is going on and so it turns out the
nervous system
interfaces the environment and then
sends signals to the cells to tell them
what's going on so the cells are
responding to the perceptions and
actions of the central nervous system
and i say why is that relevant because i
say
it's an interpretation and so the cells
the simple point
you got 50 trillion citizens and the
conscious the mind is a government yes
and the government talks to these cells
now you can have a bad
leader who tells them this is all crap
it's all falling apart things don't work
and it's like they're not going to be
happy cells
and it com profoundly different you talk
to yourselves and tell them okay
everything's cool we're great
when there's a big you know issue in the
u.s
an accident or you know big big problem
some community the president goes to the
community yes why does the president go
because it takes the attention of all
the other citizens of the of the states
focuses on the intention where that
president is so if there's an area where
there's a disaster the energy of all the
people are addressed to that area
because the president shows up there and
that's the leader so i'm saying the same
thing for yourselves you're sort of that
president in there and the point is when
you touch some part on your body your
conscious attention focuses on that part
of the body
and intention is energy and it's a
healing energy when you're sending a
good message uh to that part of the body
so you touch it talk to it and it sounds
like oh crazy i got no
you were directly sending information be
your consciousness to all the cells to
focus
healing on this part if you change the
picture in your mind you change the
chemistry change the fate so i'll give
an example
if i have a picture of love in my mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure oxytocin
bond with your loved one growth hormone
which does exactly what it says it
enhances your growth and that's why when
people fall in love the chemistry of the
brain going into the blood the culture
medium enhances vitality people glow
when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love it's not
an accident it's the chemistry of your
culture medium
but now i say but wait what if i have a
picture of fear
i go oh well love chemistry doesn't come
out when fear is in the picture the
brain releases stress hormones and
factors that affect the immune system
and growth of the system and i go oh my
goodness i say why is it relevant
changing my thought
changes my chemistry the chemistry
adjusts my biology so if i can control
my thoughts
i can control the chemistry and
therefore i control the biology that
takes me to empowerment mastery after
being programmed by medicine and biology
all these years that you're just a
victim of your genes that's 100 false
genes cannot turn on and off by
themselves they're controlled by the
signals of the environment
which are then controlled by the brain
and the consciousness and all of a
sudden it says yeah but i control those
things i go yes you do and as a result
you have power
to to heal yourself and create what you
want on this planet
how many people go through the process
find it doesn't work and then repeat the
process it doesn't work again it's like
oh oh yeah i've been married four times
somebody was saying it's like god they
repeated the same error already three
times with the ideas do you think by the
fourth time maybe you could learn that
whatever pattern you played three times
in a row will probably play itself again
until you change not your partner
you keep bringing in the same partner
with different colored hair and a
different name but you're still you
brought that person in and you play the
same game over again the question is can
you learn the answer is you can but do
many people learn the answer is no
because they keep thinking that it's
just my fate you know that's just the
way life is their subconscious still
remains unconscious that's the problem
until you change the subconscious
program you it's the subconscious is a
habitual mind it's habit
until you change the habit you will
replay the habit that's why it's called
a habit so you keep replaying the same
program it's not yeah you keep uh you
know it's like the definition of
insanity is the idea of keep doing the
same thing and expect something
different to happen the fact is though
that's insane why keep doing the same
thing you're gonna get the same thing
and if the habit mind is giving us the
story then the answer says well how do i
change it answers change the
subconscious mind because that's where
the habits are that we've got from other
people again this is most important the
fundamental habits of subconscious mind
came from other people and that's why
they rarely match
what you want in your conscious mind
which is you
and you create those programs and yet
the fundamental programs the
subconscious were downloaded during that
first six years of our development this
is a truth
but if you really understand this truth
you have to change the way you were
living
because you're living by some
materialistic darwinian newtonian give
me more matter i'll be happier and it's
like nothing to do with that at all
because happiness is is not
an object
and so what's a revolution well we've
been
programmed to
give me more matter
and it's like no
because what do you get i love it
because we did psyche training session
and there was this professional
wrestling
and his
persona in the ring is like a bad guy
so he has to dress up and you know do
the acting and the wrestling and i'm the
bad guy and everybody would boo boo him
that was his job to be booed you know
and uh he gave us psychic because he was
really depressed by it why because his
job was to be
hated by people it's like well that's
not a great job
but uh so we said well what are you
looking for he said well
if
if
i could
maybe be an announcer
for this i you know i could be an
announcer and then they say okay and you
get to be an announcer and what is that
what's that good for
well if i get to be announcer then maybe
a network
will pick me up and then i could be a
sportscaster
oh yeah and then one he said well then
i'll have some more money
and then what so then
buy more things
that was it then i could buy some more
whatever he said and then and finally
you know we kept pushing to the last one
it was like and and what do you get from
getting this
and finally after a litany
i'll be happy happiness i'll be happy so
i remember rob and i looked at him and
rob says
well you could be happy from day one you
didn't need to do any of this stuff to
be happy because even if he actually did
do all of those yes even if you simply
could say well that was a circuitous
route but at the end it did bring
happiness that would be different but we
know you go through this whole
circuitous route and don't pick it up at
the end you're still not happy no that's
what the rich people are they got all
this money but they're not happy and
it's like yeah well you can buy anything
you want it's like yeah but at some
point buying
is not happy it was i was happy to have
it i said well happy
didn't have to be it
happy could be happy
and
but people have been programmed
to conform to a machine
that requires them a to work and be
consumed
work and consume work and consume
and that will make this machine work
like this okay we came here to create
we came here to experience love
we have a sensory system if it's not
love it takes us away from our creation
we came here to have the joy of what
heaven on earth all of a sudden say
earth is heaven
earth is where you came to create
and then if you get misdirected in your
creation you can then create the world
that we have a world that doesn't look
that good to me you know uh and i guess
so why is this all relevant is because
we are truly powerful creators and we
have given up
the belief that we have any power at all
i'm afraid of this i'm afraid of that
and i'm going well there you go
fear
means closed down
growth is open the opposite growth is to
be open and in love fear is to close
down in protection we cannot survive by
closing down anything that closes down
will die
and so we have to it's the fear
and then i say so what about bruce
because you might ask me that question
what stopped the fear in my life was
i owned my spirituality as a scientific
reality i didn't go through a devotional
phase not spiritual and then i had to
learn a lot of stuff and then i became
spiritual
i was a biologist
and saw
i am not in here
i am a broadcast in that moment of
i cannot die you cannot die
you're not in there but you have to not
you know like have a devotion to
spirituality it's either you believe
spirituality you don't believe it and
for me it wasn't a devotion it was a
scientific mechanism
and the relevance was the moment i saw
that my life was just like boom
what happened i said i lost fear
and if you're not in fear no one can
control you
because fear is what makes you give up
the power to someone else in today's
world
i love the phrase because it is funny
but it's true
fake it until you make it
meaning you want to be happy but you
have to habituate happy you have to say
every day no matter if you don't if
you're not happy i don't really care you
have to tell yourself
i am happy i am happy you have to repeat
it ah habituation repetition
why
i'm consciously repeating it every day
and looking at my life my life really
sucks oh bruce i am happy i am i'm
saying that
i go well why are you saying it because
repetition
is how the subconscious mind learns i
say why is this relevant and here's the
fun part
because after i've repeated it a number
of times the subconscious says okay i'm
happy i've learned this i go why is it
relevant that 95 of the day
the subconscious function is to make
that program real if my program is i am
happy the function of the mind is to
make sure i'm happy
if the if the program says i'm going to
get cancer because i heard that from
somebody else
then the function of the mind is to make
sure i get cancer because that's the
belief i'm working with
and if if it says i am a victim and i
can't get out of this
then the function of the mind is yep
look you see you i'm showing you you're
a victim and you can't get out of it
because i'm running the show you're a
victim how did you learn anything after
age seven the answer was repetition
that's what it was it was just
practicing the more you repeat something
the more it becomes just so easy you
don't know how to play an instrument you
practice like crazy at some point you
practice so much you pick up the
instrument no
consciousness of the details of how
you're playing it it's so automatic at
this point it's like driving the car
when you first got in the car it's like
oh my god you gotta watch the window the
mirrors the gauges the engine sound
every year it's like so much
today you've been driving a car a long
time guess what
you don't even think about it put the
key in you're thinking about where
you're going and all of a sudden i saw
the more you practice the less effort it
takes to carry out whatever it was you
were practicing now the question is what
are you practicing something positive or
something negative because
they're both become programs in
whichever one you're practicing if i
have a picture of fear in my mind i'm
afraid of something my brain translates
fear with different chemicals stress
hormones cortisol norepinephrine
factors that affect immune system that
are called cytokines or histamine
so basically in a state of conscious
fear the brain releases chemistry that
complements fear that chemistry goes
into the body's blood and that changes
the behavior and the genetics of the
person
so that means there's a difference
between having positive thoughts and
having negative thoughts
and people say oh that positive thinking
doesn't really work but that's not true
the best example of positive thinking in
a scientific study is called placebo you
have a disease and doctor says here's
this new pill and it's the brand new
science and it's going to cure you and
you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill
so then you're left with
so what made me well it's not the sugar
pill it was the positive belief in that
sugar pill and how it's going to help
your life so that's called placebo
positive thinking positive result
unfortunately most people don't
recognize a more important point
negative thinking is equally powerful
but it works in the opposite direction
so it turns out for example
less than 10 of cancer is even connected
to a family lineage 90 of cancer just
comes out of the blue so to speak but
the reality is no it's a result of
stress and negative thinking
so it's important point positive
thinking negative thinking equally
powerful because that's the level of
consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics
i just want to add a very important
point to this quantum physics is the
most valid science on this planet there
is no science that has been tested more
and verified more i guess so what's the
relevance because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of our lives well no i
i am so grateful to offer this because
as each one of us takes back our power
and each one of us actually starts to
live heaven on earth like you did when
you fell in love even if it was only for
a week
if you could do that every day of your
life and everyone around you was doing
that every day of your life then the
simple truth is this then earth does
become heaven
if we are living as if it's heaven and
the function is to create the mind is to
take that vision and manifest it if i
believe i'm living in heaven then my
world experience will be what would it
be like if i lived in heaven and being
in love is the one time you
unconsciously unknowingly
took back power the equivalent of the
red build you unknowingly became
powerful and i say yeah in 24 hours you
changed your whole demeanor of life
after you met this person yeah i go
you you could have done it in different
ways didn't have to be with a person you
didn't need to fall in love with a
person you could fall in love with uh
gardening yeah if you're a gardener you
go out in the garden and you're digging
the garden you're having so much fun and
the plants are growing and everything i
go
you just manifested heaven on earth for
you it's not beautiful living in the
garden i go well it doesn't have to be
another person
the love doesn't love is just focusing
on something you desire
a pet a garden
artwork
cleaning up the garage
really you say that could be i said yeah
because when i'm doing it
i'm creating order and happiness and all
that i go well fine then you're cleaning
out the garage i'll go to clean up the
damn garage so if you're cleaning up
because wow that's so much better now i
feel so much better in here it's so
clean i know where everything is i go
being in love doesn't have it could be
anything
that keeps your conscious mind in front
because it's when you conscious mind
goes in the back
is when you become the product of your
subconscious program
so
um
and this is great and the hardest part
about programming that people don't
recognize is you have to make all
programs present
tense positive statements
not future statements i will have i
shall have you know something like that
say no i am
it is
and the reason is it's so logically
simple and that is this
uh let's say i'm not well i say i want
to be well and i say fine let's record
that oh now let's come back a whole year
later and push the button that says i
want to be well i say oh it's been a
whole year you you never got there you
just wanted to be well for a whole year
that's what the program said so if you
are sick
and you write i am healthy
and the mind looks at the program says
oh i got to change this it doesn't
change the program it brings health back
so that the body matches the program
and so
that that's the whole issue about it the
function of the mind is to take the
program and manifest it and if you've
got a negative program then obviously
whatever manifests is going to be
negative when we were in that zero to
six year period every time we got sick
we were told we had to go to the doctor
to get healed that's that's an
experiential program so what does my
subconscious mind learn from this
experience every time i'm sick i have to
go to the doctor why
apparently it's a step before you get
healed so we build that into the program
and then which is interesting is that we
have an innate ability to heal ourselves
that's what the placebo effect is all
about
but when we put in a program that says i
have to go to the doctor before i get
healed then what you do is actually
stall your own ability to heal yourself
until you go to the doctor and the joke
many people get well on the way to the
doctor without having any treatment and
the reason is they already have the
ability to get well but the program
steps said until you do this next step
then the healing doesn't start
so we
deprogram our ability to heal ourselves
something you look at in spontaneous
evolution too is how
science and spirituality are coming
together they used to be very separate
absolutely
the scientific world which is very
factual driven and that's that and you
couldn't change it and spirituality was
trying to open up things but they really
are meeting now aren't they yeah it was
interesting because um the spiritual
world of religion was talking about the
invisible moving forces that shape the
physical reality and we call them spirit
and then science uh
only came into existence because it made
a detent with the church in the very
early days of science it said look
we won't tread on your invisible
spiritual domain we will just study the
physical world and when newton was able
to predict the movements of the planet
by just looking at the physical features
then scientists got the ideas well if
you can understand how the universe
operates by just stunning the material
where we don't need that invisible stuff
but in 1925
newtonian physics was
incorporated subsumed by a bigger
physics called quantum physics and
quantum physics emphasizes the universe
is made out of energy it's not made out
of matter and then i say well what does
the quantum physicists call this energy
that the universe is made out of i say
well they call it the field i said
what's the definition of the field i
love this
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world i go my goodness
that's the same definition as spiritual
it's used for spirit i go yes quantum
physics emphasizing the invisible
field as primary to the physical world
is essentially reiterating
the statement of the spiritual people
who talked about the invisible forces
shaping our physical existence and so by
definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with the spiritual reality
hopefully
the the dogmatic beliefs of the church
which had talked about these wonderful
terms but didn't allow us to live there
and science which is still stuck in its
material plane will both divest
themselves of their dogma
and allow us to come together and
recognize that we're all
part of that invisible field that we
don't even live in our own bodies if you
understand the nature of how the cell
works that we are part of the field
being downloaded into our body that
we're all by definition the field or
we're all spiritual same definition
and and if we recognize this the unity
of it and that you cannot be taken out
of the field and you cannot be in a
sense punished by the field you are the
field
then maybe the beliefs those very
restrictive beliefs from both science
and from the dogmatic religion
will disappear
because the people owning their own
spirituality owning their own
responsibility
and not saying oh which spirits that did
this or things other factors that we are
the creators
will generate a new world because what i
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world and say if you could create a
world what would you like well i'd like
a world where there's peace and harmony
and i like some food and a job and i go
isn't it amazing how everywhere you go
in the world virtually entire population
has the same belief i go then how come
we don't have any answers because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so i trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world
and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together
we will create magic on this earth like
nothing has ever been seen before so i'm
very optimistic about that how do you
rewire your brain
well as we just said the first thing you
have to do is say what are my programs
you don't have to fix a program if it
works the only one you want to fix is
the one that doesn't work so then you
say well what are the programs that i
can already tell you the things that
don't work in your life that you desire
to have in your life and you are
creating an effort and a struggle and a
lot of work to make it happen
the reason why it's not working is
because somewhere in the program it
doesn't support that conclusion so this
program does not allow you to have this
so the thing is well as long as i have
this program i'm never going to get this
and even if i get it it's going to
disappear if i you know as soon as i let
go of the control it's going to
disappear because it's sabotage
away
so the first thing is identify well
where are you having trouble
uh and i said whatever that destination
is that the thing you were looking for
whether it was a job health relationship
whatever
if that's where you're having a trouble
recognize this
the program
is counter to that
it's the opposite the program is the
opposite that's why this can't stay here
because this is gonna 95 percent of the
day create a different program
not the one you wanted so i say so if i
have a troubled relationship then
basically uh my program for relationship
doesn't work very well in my case that
was true i uh you know for 50 years
i was operating from the program of
relationship that i downloaded from my
parents who had a really sucky
relationship it was so bad and i was
just manifesting it unconsciously until
i started a change
once i changed
now i have heaven on earth you as an
identity are in your conscious mind you
actually are in there that's where your
personal identity is
and we have a tendency to say if i talk
to myself
i'm going to give myself a good talking
to and i'm going to change that
subconscious i say to myself bruce don't
do that again do this don't do that
again and and then i say it's very
frustrating why
you can talk until you're blue in the
face
and nothing will change i say why and
the answer is and this is the most
important part
there is nobody in the subconscious
there's nothing there it's a machine
it's a record playback device so you can
talk to the machine as much as you want
if you don't know how to push the record
button nothing's going to happen
so then i say how do you change the
program i said how did you get the
program
the first seven years your brain was in
theta hypnosis
so i say you want to change a program
every night when you go to bed just as
your mind disconnects just as you fall
into sleep your brain is now operating
in theta
so if you put earphones on your head
and you play a tape a program a cd
of what you want
as your your conscious mind disconnected
your subconscious is downloading so you
just play that
tape as you go to bed and after a number
of playings your subconscious will learn
the new program without even your
conscience being involved that's number
one
after age seven
how do we put a program in repetition
how did you do anything you repeated it
over and over again how long did it take
you to learn the alphabet how many times
did you have to go from a to zed before
you could remember the whole alphabet
when you drove a car you didn't know how
to drive a car until you did what you
practiced you repeated so if you want to
change a program
you put into your mind a repetition
and it's not
it recognizes this what you want to
change doesn't exist so when you put in
the new program it'll sound strange so
let's say you are sick you have a
disease and i say what program do i want
i am healthy
i go it doesn't sound right i know i'm
sick i say i don't care there's a saying
in english
fake it until you make it
what that means is if you want to be
happy just keep in your mind i am happy
i smile even if you have to force a
smile i am happy i'm smiling i say
repeat this and repeat this and guess
what
after a short time it becomes a habit
and when you're in that habit you don't
even have to think i am happy the new
habit will keep you happy all the time
because that's the new program so
someone's not feeling well they've got
i don't know they've got the flu or
they've got something on their stomach
or something
what should they practically do they
should presumably go to the doctor and
get a diagnosis would you go along with
that i'm just i'm just trying to see
where this goes in day-to-day life well
i wouldn't say don't go to a doctor but
i say before you go to a doctor just
look around and think about this what's
going on in your life where the stress
is coming from because it's almost uh
your physiological expression is a
complement to your life experiences
those people that are happy are healthy
as i said when you're in the honeymoon
you didn't get sick in the honeymoon
that's when you're absolutely healthy
but when you got caught back up into
real life that's when illnesses start to
occur so we always look at oh i must be
sick there must be something wrong with
my biology when it turns out
it didn't begin with your biology only
about two percent of illness is actually
connected to genetics let's say
98 of illness is not just genetics it's
environment so when a person says i have
the breast cancer gene
and people think oh i'm going to get
breast cancer and i said well wait wait
50 percent of women that have the breast
cancer gene get cancer
what about the 50 percent that have the
gene and didn't get the cancer and we
never study that side we only study the
side that got the cancer and you find
out well what is it that the 50
do
that don't have the cancer yet have the
gene what's different the answer is
their lifestyle is different their
stresses their fears their concerns are
are not the same as the one that get the
illness
the genes are like give you a propensity
to get a disease but that propensity is
based on how you perceive life
and it's interesting uh studies show
that when children get adopted into a
cancer family the adopted child will get
the cancer with the same percentage of
probability as any of the natural
sibling and you say yeah but the child
came from totally different genetic
stock and the point is yes it wasn't the
genes that promoted the cancer it was
the lifestyle that promoted the cancer
especially the lifestyle of stress
and then i said well if stress is
causing lifestyle i look around at the
world and i go my god no wonder
everybody's sick every day is filled
with more stress than the day before and
if you buy into the stress you take that
disharmonious vibration essentially
bring it in your life and you end up
with disharmony inside your body your
life is a reflection of what you see
we've been so programmed to devalue
ourselves and deep you know disempower
ourselves that we look at ourselves as
victims and frail uh biological entities
you know ripe for bacteria to eat us up
and all these other things it's like
this is totally untrue
so the issue is we have to start from
that belief and change these beliefs of
who we are we are profoundly powerful
people
look you can walk across hot coals you
know
a woman can lift a car off of an infant
without thinking about it um down south
the
baptist fundamentalists of the
pentecostal faith work themselves up in
a jesus state and drink strychnine in
toxic doses to demonstrate that god
protects them they're not harmed by the
strychnine i mean you can walk across
fire you can drink poison you can lift
thousands of pounds
where's the frail image come from and
that's a belief
but the problem is if you believe you
are frail if you believe you are
susceptible if you believe you have a
terminal illness
they manifest because that's called the
nocebo effect they did a recent study
where they looked at some genes
controlling inflammation
and then they had they read the genes of
these people
and then the people went to eight hours
of meditation
and at the end of eight hours the
genetic activity was completely changed
in other words you can change the genes
in just eight hours
of a meditation and that means how
powerful your thought is in controlling
your biology i was a scientist and as a
scientist we don't bring spirituality
and mind into the story it's all genes
and cells and molecules and all that
and my research
on on stem cells
revealed that while i was teaching in
medical school that genes control life
my research revealed that it was the
environment in which the cells lived
that control the cells it was outside
information coming into the cells
and i remember how specifically in a
moment of time
that i was working on trying to
understand the mechanics from a
molecular point of view how does an
environmental signal control biology
and i was working not on the genes i was
working on the skin of the cell the
membrane
and it was
it was so profound i it's hard for me to
even describe it i'm working on the
understanding how does information from
the environment control biology and i
had
looked at the membrane for years and i
wrote a new definition of the mechanism
of the membrane
and i wrote this definition and this is
in 1985. it was about 2 am
and i wrote down the membrane
is a liquid crystal
semiconductor
with gates and channels
when i wrote that down there was a pause
and i said
i i just i read something exactly like
that
and right next to my first computer
macintosh
was a book from a simple book of
understanding your microprocessor
and i opened it up and i said somewhere
and i open it right in the introduction
it said
a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with gates
and channels
and i thought oh what a coincidence
they have the same definition
and then in a couple of seconds i
started to say wait a minute
one for one the parts are exactly the
same i said oh oh my god
the membrane is a computer chip
and
on the surface of the cellar like keys
like on a typewriter
and and i started to realize oh my
goodness the environment
is typing
on the surface of the cell information
that went into the cell
and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
really exciting and i'm typing on my own
computer typing this information and
then i realize
i am outside of the computer
typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then i said
oh my god
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells
has a number of keys
that represent a pin number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same
keys on that each of us have a different
pin number to get into our own cells
it's our personal identity and these are
the keys and i realized oh my god
while we've been focusing on these what
are called receptors as the source of
identity i realize no
it's what's activating what's typing is
the identity and then it hit me and said
oh my god
my identity is not in the cell my
identity is a signal coming from the
environment typing on the keyboard and
then i said
oh
and the first thing that hit me was
i can't die
i'm not even in here
an instant the fear which all of us have
in our deepest bottom belief system
is a fear of my mortality
and when that moment of like i can't die
not as a devotional belief it had
nothing to do with that it was just a
mechanism i said oh my god i can't die
i'll tell you the same thing happened
with savages me
tears started rolling down my face and
this joy was an ache in my heart that
i've never experienced before i spent 40
years in my head that's how i became an
academician and a research scientist and
when this moment hit it was my heart
that blew open i refer to it as a heart
orgasm and
and that was the first time i
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence
and what happened was
i was overwhelmed
first with the fact that i was not
spiritual at 1 59 a.m
and at 2 a.m i was 100 spiritual you
have a very close friend you know your
friend's behavior and you happen to know
your friend's parent and at some point
you see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill
because bill's the first guy that says
how can you compare me to my dad and
everyone laughs because they're familiar
but i say no there's two very profound
points from that one story and profound
point number one everybody else can see
that bill behaves like his dad he got
his programming from his dad it's only
bill who doesn't see it yeah and
profound point number two we're all bill
because all of us got programming and
all of us operate with these programs
and we don't even see we're doing that
we even when told we're doing it we'll
deny that we do these behaviors because
we don't even see what we're doing
that's why it's called subconscious
below conscious when i first started
talking about it it was from an academic
conscious point of view this is what i
learned but my subconscious programs are
still exactly the same so well i had
this wonderful knowledge my life still
wasn't anything i wanted to to brag
about it because it wasn't and
and as you know that old game well who
would you like to be and i could think
of anybody i'd rather be than me and yet
when i started to apply the new science
and rewrite the subconscious so it
supported me rather than the programs of
limitation or disempowerment that we get
from our parents and our community as
children which almost all of us get when
i put in the new programs all of a
sudden i started to find my goodness my
life completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life i was healthier i've been to a
doctor in 20 years i i don't need that i
don't take any of their drugs why
because
most of the illness is just from the
stress of not living in harmony and when
you learn to to get rid of the limiting
programs that we got as children and put
in programs that support you guess what
then all of a sudden the place turns
into heaven uh and it's interesting
people i tell people you create your own
life and then they look around and go i
don't want responsibility for this but i
say well you didn't know you were
creating with these unconscious beliefs
and and yet then i tell people
especially people that have fallen in
love and people have fallen head over
heels and love i said go back to that
time when you first fell in love
let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah i was i was healthy
as anything i said you have energy i
said oh i had so much energy made love
for days in a row without even eating
and i go yeah and i go uh and how was
life for you it was so exciting i
couldn't wait for the next day so i said
in this little period that you you know
that i refer to as a honeymoon i say
wasn't life like heaven on earth and
they go well yeah and i go you know that
was not an accident that was an actual
creation and you say but what was
different that made life
so heaven on earth during love and the
answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date i say
especially the women i said how long did
it take you to get dressed and they said
i was 15 minutes and i was out of the
house and then i say now tonight you're
going to go on a date with this person
who has just rocked your world and i
said how long does it take you to get
dressed it's like my god it may take an
hour or two and i say
yesterday 15 minutes today an hour or
two what's the difference yesterday i
got dressed by habit because i get
dressed every day but tonight i am
looking in the mirror meaning i am
self-conscious i am making sure that i
represent myself to be the fully the
best individual i can be and when both
parties are not relying on the habit and
both of them are saying i'm creating the
best i can be they're living in the
moment of the now they're being very
mindful they're being very present and
guess what
heaven on earth is created many people
may think well hold on a second so i can
take five minutes and i can totally
change my life and that's all i need and
i think well that's a really a wonderful
possibility
but the probability is this are you
going to hit the right statement
that is the one that you need to change
your life okay uh let's say someone's
overweight
and they say in their mind i i am you
know a weightless a number they like i
am 125 pounds and you're not
uh and i say uh so i want to change my
weight and i put a program in i'm going
to lose weight
and i go but well wait
that extra poundage uh that might be due
to protection like what do you mean
if i as an as a young person was abused
then the consciousness is if i'm a heavy
person they won't bother me anymore
and so the weight isn't due to just
eating food the weight would
move to
i'm safer
being heavy than i am i say well if you
want to change your weight you can talk
about the weight all you want but until
you adjust the problem from
the the fear uh you know that i'm going
to be abused that's where the problem
came from it didn't come from eating
food over here so i said yeah well you
can change beliefs
sometimes i like to give a visual a
matter of fact i visualize a big spider
web which has like circles and then
lines coming out you know like a web
okay
and so there are links as you go around
there's also anchors where the web is
anchored at a couple of places and i go
each belief is like a link
in that spider web and you can do one
link and another link and another link
that really changes fire web
but if you do a belief that is an anchor
and you change the anchor belief and
that anchor lets go
the web will collapse that's possible
the point is this sometimes a belief
statement knocks out a link
but when you really hit it just right
you knock out a support
and when you knock out a major support
the whole web
collapses instead of just a link at a
time which could take it down but it's
much harder
the belief that is taught is that
biology in the world we live in operates
according to newtonian principles
uh unfortunate part about that is
quantum mechanics 100 years ago said
that's obviously not true and physicists
know this is not true and yet medicine
doesn't buy into it because it still
focuses on the material reality and lets
go of the invisible shaping fields that
quantum physics emphasizes as primary
okay so we got we have to change that
belief system we have to get people to
recognize that the field and the
thoughts and all these other things are
as important as anything else in shaping
the matter we live in
uh number two uh the belief which i you
know i blew away years ago but it's
still being taught in school is the
concept that genes control life
this is totally false genes control
nothing control is an action
a gene is a blueprint it's a physically
literally a string with blueprint data
on it
why is that relevant
it's interesting go to an architect's
office and the architect's working on a
blueprint and then lean over the
architect's shoulder and say is that
blueprint on or off
and he looks at you
the blueprint's not on or off it's a
blueprint yeah but we talk about genes
being on and off like genes are turning
on and genes are turning off and the
question is but genes are blueprints
they can't turn on and off there is no
on and off it's just the blueprint it's
a pattern
what we have failed to focus on because
we gave genes a character of
self-actualization
that my genes decided to do something
it's like okay now we're a victim of the
genes but it turns out biologists know
that this is not true biologists know
that genes are not turned on and off
jeans are red or not red like blueprints
then all of a sudden it says well it's
not the blueprint that's important if
the blueprints were self-actualizing an
architect could go by a building site
drop the blueprints off come back two
weeks later and the building will be
there that's what we think about
animals and plants the genes are
blueprints and their control all this is
like no
the blueprints are important i'm not
saying they're not you've got the bad
blueprints you've got some problems
going on here but the issue is it's not
the presence or absence of a blueprint
it's whether the blueprint is being read
and then you say well then who reads the
blueprint the answer is a contractor
and who's the contractor
the mind is the contractor the mind
reads genes the mind can change the
genes read out here here's something so
blow away that most people can't in
their conventional world make sense of
it because it's like it goes like this
the mind through what is called
epigenetic mechanisms
can
start with a single gene blueprint
and create over 30 000 different
versions of products from the same
blueprint thirty thousand different
products from the same blueprint all of
a sudden you realize my god
you can infinitely vary the expression
of the gene and the answer is yes
and why is this become relevant to all
of us and the answer is because many of
us think genes control our lives and yet
we don't realize that we modify the
readout of the genes so we could be
totally healthy and our mind can cause
cancer our mind can cause any disease
diabetes anything like that
and and what's interesting is the flip
side
is some people come here with actually
defective genes
and guess what with their mind they can
rewrite those genes and make them normal
so the genes are not the limiting factor
it's the mind the simple truth is sad
vijay said
you cannot change anyone but yourself
and if you try
and you start to realize you put all
that effort in to help somebody and it
doesn't come back
they're not affected by it you're the
one that's affected by it
if you know this the best thing to do is
to recognize you can be a model
of what you want
but you can't really make anybody else
unless they want it
they will not change
so
helping somebody
only works if they ask for the help
if they don't ask for that help
that you're using up your energy and
it's not coming back and i
really feel that's the most important
thing because how frustrated we feel
when we know that somebody could do
better or be healthier
and and you could help them and they're
not listening
it's not in their program at that time
when their program is ready to change
they will come to you
and ask for the help instead of us going
to them
it will save your energy save your life
and your joy and you could use it to a
much better effect by creating an area
an aura an energy around yourself that
others want that
and then you will become the teacher
and that's what it's all about you talk
about again in in your first book about
how
cells automatically move away from
toxicity and towards nutrition yes and
it seems that
as human beings that's something that
we're trying to do but we get it wrong a
lot of the time we're trying to move
away from unhappiness or what we think
makes us happy and towards what we think
makes us happy but we get it muddled up
don't we well yeah but you see the key
word you said is what we think makes us
happy so i mean i was caught in that in
the old days too before i became aware i
thought at one point wow
i'm gonna buy that little you know that
car but bought a car that looked like a
ferrari called the pantera back in the
70s and i thought okay i'm gonna be
happy i i got this great car so i got
the car and about like three days later
it's like now i got this car i'm not any
happier and a matter of fact i got now
three speeding tickets because every day
i took the car out
of course i couldn't go 30 miles an hour
with it so uh
every day it was like the car became a
burden to me and it was all of a sudden
said well you know that whole program
that that ferrari's going to make you
happy
that that was a missed program
it wasn't the car that makes you happy
and i started to find out it wasn't the
material things that make you happy what
makes you happy love makes you happy
good food will make you happy harmony in
your environment makes you happy these
things are the harmony environment
where's the price tag on that one you
know
basically having a relationship with
somebody that supports you and fulfills
you where's the price tag
we always bought the oh money gives you
happiness so we have all those billions
of people out there every day running in
the streets how much money can i make
because if i get enough money i'm going
to be happy and then you find out even
people the most money are not happy and
it was programming was wrong
if we were programmed to seek out
companionship and community and love
that's where you make us happy don't
want to say don't go to the doctor so
i'll go back just 20 years ago the last
time i went to a doctor okay i went to a
doctor because i had pneumonia and i
said to myself well yeah i can see why
at that moment in my life there was so
much stress going on in my life that i
could see i was i had opened my system
up to that but then i also realized okay
well i can you know handle this with my
consciousness but then i realized the
bacteria were doubling and they're
growing faster than i can handle my
consciousness so i said okay now is the
time for some penicillin
but the concept of it was i don't rely
on the penicillin and and all i had to
say was look i get back on my feet and i
go
it was my responsibility
and if i don't get into that same
stressful situation again then i won't
have to go through this again and it's
been 20 years so it's intelligent
learning yes don't don't discard
the element of medicine until your
consciousness gets high
and the fact is when people have lower
consciousness
because they're not strong enough in
their consciousness to really manifest
everything they want they really need to
take care of themselves more eat better
better nutrition do more exercises do
these things to add to your health but
the surprising thing is if you get more
and more and more conscious there's a
point where you get so conscious then
you become like the
the the person we refer to as jesus who
does all these miracles and well and
what did what what did jesus say about
the miracles he said
you could do these better than i can do
them but you don't believe and that is
the absolute truth because when you
fully have control of your consciousness
with that belief you do create the
miracles the miracles of spontaneous
remission for example a person
terminally ill who all of a sudden says
i'm not buying this i'm going to change
my vision of life and the moment they
change their perception
they have what's called a spontaneous
remission again that would be called a
miracle but what was it taking full
control of consciousness and manifesting
a life of being fully conscious and
present and seeing what brings harmony
into your life and avoiding or
eliminating as best you can any of the
disharmony that exists on the outside
because disharmony will make disharmony
inside well i probably don't have to
tell you this if you've been watching tv
reading the newspaper going online or
even looking out your window
the world is in a state of upheaval
crises are all over the planet crises
based on economics politics religion
race are upsetting the nature of
civilization as we have known it well
this is not an accident actually this is
right on time on time yes we're facing
an evolutionary upheaval the
significance is profound science has
recognized that human behavior is
precipitating the sixth mass extinction
of life on this planet five times in the
history of this planet life was thriving
in some event wiped out from 70 to 95
percent of all life the last time this
happened 66 million years ago a comet
hit the planet upended the ecosystem and
the dinosaurs disappeared forever
well guess what we are now in the sixth
mass extinction human behavior is
causing this the way out is to change
behavior but to understand that we need
to understand that you are not a victim
not a victim of your genes not a victim
of the world as quantum physics
emphasizes consciousness is creating our
life experiences when i show up on
september 27th in copenhagen on friday
night i'm going to provide a
presentation to inform you of why this
upheaval is occurring the future of our
evolution and more importantly how
powerful you are in creating the
character of the life you want as
quantum physics the most valid science
on this planet acknowledges
consciousness is creating our life
experiences well my presentation will go
deep into the nature of consciousness
and how our mind controls our genes
controls the behavior that we have and
the life that we express and when you
understand that you've been programmed
and it's time for us to get out of this
program to recognize how truly powerful
you are
this is the opportunity to take charge
of your life and so what we need to
understand is this
a
you are not a victim of your heredity
because epigenetics the new science
reveals that you are controlling your
genetic and behavioral activity and more
so
we want to understand a very important
fact
there's more to us in this physical body
that there's a field of energy with our
identity which is also recognized as a
spirit and if you recognize how powerful
you really are and that you are more
than this physical body you will have
the opportunity to take charge of your
life and create the wishes and desires
and aspirations that you seek jesus told
his followers
all the miracles that i can do you can
do them but even better than i can and
you don't believe it and that was the
whole damn thing in a nutshell
if you don't believe it you can't do it
and i say well where's belief come from
mind i say and then what have you been
programmed you can't do and i say then
you'll never be able to do it
and this is the problem and and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know you that what
you said was true
evenings just say i feel amazing i feel
amazing if you repeat that the mind will
will all of a sudden change how you feel
that's that's how it doesn't okay so i
say number one self-hypnosis number two
after age seven you still learn how to
do new things that become habits like
you didn't learn how to drive a car
until until later then seven but once
you know how to drive a car remember the
first day you got in it was like oh my
god looking out the windows checking the
mirror watching the gauges keeping your
feet on the pedals just correctly you
know looking paying all these attentions
like
and i say today you've been driving for
a while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am i going to do when i get to the
store
you're not even thinking about driving
why it's a habit okay i say well how'd
you get that habit because you're older
than seven how'd you get it i said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
i'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and i say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way of subconscious
learns
repeating something over and over and
over again because that's called
habituation
making a habit and i love it the new age
today thing is fake it till you make it
like what the hell is that i say you're
not happy yeah most of us have trouble
being happy and i say but what if every
day all day long and you can remember
you say i am happy in spite of the fact
that what the hell is going on you just
say i am happy
i am happy
i am happy i go why what's going on i
say repetition
and there'll be a point where you're
repeated to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
will put in i am happy i say then what's
the consequences of what's the function
of the mind take that program and
manifest it now that it's in there i am
happy i wake up one morning guess what i
don't have to say i'm happy it's
automatic i'm already happy all day long
my program said that 95 is coming from
that habituation
you know repetition
of the exact thing you want not future
vision as if you have it now
we'll put it in a program so that's
first seven years hypnosis after seven
years uh repetition habituation is how
you change it
a sticky note people put that stuff on a
mirror or someplace and they go oh yeah
the little sticky note and i go that is
not repetition that's a suggestion
a repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving the car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real
okay so the first two things are
uh hypnosis
second thing is repetition
and thirdly the most
you know
effective
is called energy psychology and i go
what's energy psychology
it's called super learning so what the
hell is super learning i go maybe you've
seen somebody read a book
by picking up a book and just moving
their finger down the page just like
that just as fast as that
and guess what
the subconscious mind the super computer
that it is has read every word just by
moving your finger down that has read
every word on that page and a person
using this super learning technique can
go into a bookstore open up a book in
five minutes later by thumbing through
each page turn the page turn the page
turn the page they can read a whole book
in five minutes that's super learning i
say if you can engage that function
you can also use super learning to
create
new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes
it's like
i go absolutely and it's so important
why because uh there's an old phrase
that's really critical it's called
necessity as the mother of invention
and i say what's happening we're facing
a mass extinction due to human behavior
that is compromising the web of life
humans are creating this through our
behavior our culture i say you want to
survive this epi this whole you know
extinction event
well then you have to create something
different
you have to change behavior on a
beautiful spring day bill is celebrating
his 16th birthday and his father hands
him the keys to the car and says bill
this is your first solo trip please be
careful and enjoy this experience
thanks mom thanks dad for letting me use
the car
he's very excited when he sees his
friends and waves hello to them being
the proud owner of a new driver's
license
hi miles hey i really like your new
electric train set
[Music]
hi gabe lily annabelle i want to come
and visit you tomorrow and jump on your
trampoline
oh this is so wonderful
and he drives down the street further
and all of a sudden something catches
bill's attention
oh the check engine light is flashing
it's red
i don't know what to do something might
be wrong but i told dad i'd take care of
his car and the engine light's flashing
i don't know not sure what it is bill
drives into the local gas station where
he sees the mechanic
there's a gas station i'm going to go in
there
wow i'm lucky i made it into the garage
before anything went wrong with the car
well bill what simply made a problem
here well hi mr john i'm having a
problem with the service engine light
that's flashing i don't know what to do
about it
well they'll gotta be easy fix you go
wait in the waiting room and i'll come
and get you when the job is done thank
you mr john my dad will be real happy to
have the car fixed
bill goes into the shop and the mechanic
gets behind the wheel
well it's the red tech engine life for
sure
and he puts his hand up under the
dashboard and he pulls out the light
bulb from the surface engine light
warning lamp oh that got a good idea
[Music]
well that'll stop it from blinking for
sure
now the lamp isn't flashing anymore the
engine is running the car seems to be in
very good condition
wow the check engine light is off i'm so
happy mr john fixed this car because dad
would be very happy too
happy to be a service bill he feels very
happy and excited about this because now
he's going off to finish the wonderful
drive in the country that he started a
little while ago but
unbeknownst to bill
the problem has not been solved with the
issue in this car oh no
oh no oh no
i thought the car was fixed i thought it
was fixed
and the moral of the story is very
profound because it's a metaphor about
life
consider your body as a vehicle such as
a car
however instead of a dashboard with
lights on it we have emotions and
symptoms that express how our vehicle is
running so we should recognize this
when we have feelings in our body and
when we have symptoms these are not
negative experiences these are very
important information providing
awareness messages these are messages
that something is going on in our body
that we have to deal with the cells in
your body are covered up by the skin
disconnected from the environment but in
order to survive these cells have to
adjust their genetics and their behavior
to adapt and maintain their survival in
a changing environment so the question
is then how do the cells inside your
body
actually know what's going on in the
real world because they're not connected
to it i go this is the role of the
nervous system the nervous system's job
is to read environmental signals and
then relay those signals into the cell
so as illustrated right here we are
getting signals from two different
environments in our body signals from
within our body as well as signals from
without our body and the function of the
nervous system is to read both of these
environments
the relevance is the nervous system
reads the information in the environment
and then translates it into signals that
are sent to the 50 trillion cells inside
your body to alert them to what is going
on in that world so in fact that is a
true statement the environment is
controlling the behavior of your cells
but the mind does an interpretation of
those signals based on our life
experiences now for a lot of people this
seems difficult but let's put it in a
different context because we can talk
about computers there's a very
interesting fact about our brain as a
computer because it has an auto correct
mechanism built into the subconscious
meaning what well i can have my
conscious mind like typing on the
computer about what's going on in the
world
but if i type something that signal can
be translated and sent to the cells
but if i type something that the
subconscious has no recognition of it
will do like an autocorrect and change
what i wrote to fit something that it
thinks that i wrote as a subconscious so
i put in
love and subconscious changes that to
live that's a whole different meaning at
this point because of misinterpretation
so the point is
your wishes and desires of your
conscious mind are filtered by the
programs in your subconscious mind and
if you have a wish or desire that
doesn't conform to a program that
already exists then the subconscious
mind's job is to re-translate that into
something that makes sense for the
subconscious belief not for the
conscious
so uh we may have wonderful wishes and
desires
and if it doesn't conform to the
programs that we receive
the subconscious will change those into
something it understands to make sense
of what i just said consider using your
cell phone that you write something in
your cell phone such as let's put the
word epigenetics in the cell phone and i
go
when i type epigenetics in the database
in the phone says i don't know that word
at all and then what does it do it
throws up different options that could
be closely related to epigenetics and so
the significance is if i put something
into my system that is not supported by
the program
then the programming system will change
whatever i did to accommodate what it
believes is right now the issue about
this is well if i want to have
epigenetics in my phone then what i
really have to do is open up my
dictionary and add the word epigenetics
and now after that anytime i write up a
genetics the phone mechanism will
understand what i'm talking about well
going into the database and changing the
program is the function of what energy
psychology is all about it says if your
behavior is not conforming to your
wishes and desires then it will be
necessary to go into your program and
install new behaviors that you want to
manifest so now the brain will have a
reflection or resource of what you're
talking about so i really want to
emphasize the nature of biology belief
is different than the fact that just
environment controls your genes and i'll
give you a very simple example of what i
mean by that but the fact that i can
have two people
in the very exact same environment
but each of these individuals has a
totally different reaction to the
environment
so if it was just environment that
controls your genes and your behavior
then both individuals should have exact
same behavior but the reality is no
the two people have different responses
to the environment i go why same
environment
but their minds have different
interpretations and it's the
interpretation of the mind
about that environment that is sent to
the cells
so the important part is this yes
environment controls epigenetics
there's an external environment
but an internal environment
and that recognized in humans the
internal environment is not a direct
readout from the external world
it's an interpretation of that external
world and that's why each of us has a
different response to the world in which
we live
and that is why the biology of belief is
an extension
of the foundation that environment
controls epigenetics being a biologist i
want to talk about a different aspect of
service but it's the same thing because
my dear friend savage was talking about
service and how we can influence the
world around us i want to give you an
interesting biological insight about
your own personal consequence of being
in service
and basically it has to deal with the
dna in your cells i say what does that
mean i say well
the dna is the genetic code i say and
every time the cell divides
you have to copy that code and so if i
can try to make an image with my hand
here imagine my arm is the dna
and i say it's time to copy it
there's a protein so let's say the
microphone okay thank you
that my arm my hand is the copying
device it's like a train on a railroad
track
as the train moves down the dna it
leaves behind a copy of the dna it just
rode over
i say well that's really cool except
guess what when the train gets to the
end of the dna
it can't copy the part where the train
is sitting on it so it copied everything
all the way up to here but can't copy
this piece so when i copy it the new
piece is shorter than the original piece
and so every time you copy every time
the cell divides the dna gets a little
shorter than it did before
and i say well why is this relevant
because if you make a shorter piece of
dna when you copy it then every time
you're copying it you're interfering
with the genetic code
so it's like well nature would say oh my
god if every time the cell divides
pretty soon i'll chop that dna up and
i'll have a problem
but nature of course being
quite intelligent adds a piece of dna at
the end that is not the gene it's just
an extension it's called a telomere you
may have heard the word telomere and i
say what is it it's an extra railroad
track but it's not the genes and i say
why is it relevant because every time i
copy it i lose a piece of the telomere
but i didn't cut into the genes
and i say well what's aging all about
and here's what we now know aging
depression and disease
result when you copy the dna so many
times that you run out of that track of
telomere and the next time you copy
you're cutting off the gene which
interferes with your biology
so originally it was thought oh the
telomeres have a fixed length and every
time it divides you lose a piece of the
length and the scientists back in the
60s leonard hey flick calculated how
many times can a cell divide before it
runs out of telomere and it came out oh
it was about 50 to 60 cell divisions i
say well why is that relevant because
our stem cells which keep us alive
when they keep dividing what happens
after your stem cells went through 50
cell divisions now your stem cells won't
work anymore and now you can't replace
your cells in your body and that's when
they said oh humans have a given
lifetime you know 90
100 years at max uh and that's your
lifetime because that's when you run out
of telomeres
that was very depressing
because it says oh my god if i'm under
stress i actually cut the telomeres even
faster the more stress you're under the
more that disappears
now and it was because of again a woman
scientist because they always come up
with the neat stuff that the men are not
looking at
a woman scientists found there was an
enzyme an enzyme called telomerase
telo
enzyme telomerase and i say what's that
enzyme it adds the length of the
telomere so as the cells are dividing if
you can activate this enzyme
it will extend the telomeres so the
cells have a relatively unlimited
lifespan
and so the relevance is the belief that
we only live 100 years is mainly a
consequence of not being able to
continue to extend the telomeres in a
normal person
so they start to find out well what
influences the telomere
well the biggest thing is lack of love
if you don't if you have a lack of love
the feedback will shut off the
telomerase enzyme
if uh you have stress in your life
stress shuts off the enzyme
if you have no gratitude
or
appreciation of life it shuts off the
enzyme why well if you don't like life
then why give you an extra life that's
the enzyme is just responding but now it
comes down to the opposites of those
love
and self-love which is most critical
is one of the the big drivers of
telomerase
gratitude
and joy of being in this world enhances
the enzyme why if you love the world you
want more and the cells will give you
more
but now and it's a beautiful question
the most important
contributor to telomerase activity is
service
that you are doing something on this
planet you have a mission to do
something and that your nervous system
is telling yourselves i'm not ready to
go i have a job to do
and caregivers for example live an
extraordinarily longer healthier life
than other people why a caregiver's
mentality is i have to service and help
these people and therefore i cannot
leave yet and i have to be healthy
the feedback from the nervous system to
the cells activates telomerase so the
simple line is this
if we have a mission and we have
something to do on this planet
you will activate telomerase service is
one of the primary things
so it says if you're just meandering
through the earth nice you're going to
end around 90.
but if you're in service to the world
you can extend your life
and right now biologists
somewhat agree that our minimum
lifespan is 140 years
medical science has revealed that from
one-third to two-thirds which is
significant of all healing whether it's
drug-related or surgery or whatever
healing process
the healing didn't come about from the
process the healing came about because
the person believed the process was
going to heal them so if i give you this
brand new drug and it's purple colored
because that makes it really special you
know
and it's funny because there is a drug a
purple drug and they said it's purple
and everybody's like oh wow that's got
to be special but people believe that
the drug holds this effect
and you give the person this drug
and all of a sudden they heal themselves
and they say yeah the drug did it and
then you tell them later but it was just
a sugar pill
that that healing didn't come from the
drug it came from the belief in the drug
so the belief in healing
the mind again isn't it yeah it's again
the power of belief in this case it's a
very positive belief that this procedure
drug or whatever is going to heal me but
what people haven't talked about because
everyone knows about the placebo effect
is that
the placebo effect i don't know is based
on a positive thinking what is the
consequence of negative thinking ah well
science has a term for it but it hasn't
really come out in the public it's
called the nocebo effect and the nocebo
effect has been revealed by science that
a negative thought can not only make you
ill but a negative thought could also
kill you you can be scared to death in
us in a real sense okay
and and why is that important because it
turns out it's not just the positive
thought of placebo that's influential
the negative thought works the same way
with the same power but in the opposite
direction so basically it's not placebo
no sibo
it comes down simply this it's the power
of thought
and a positive thought will move you in
a healing direction and a negative
thought will move you into an illness
direction
but before i get off that topic i don't
want people to go out there in the
audience and go oh oh one of those
positive thinking kind of guys is like
it's more than just positive thinking
it's a commitment and an intention of
positive thinking it also really needs
the support of your subconscious belief
because if your subconscious belief is
going oh that new age weirdos stuff
that's what your subconscious is
programmed to believe and yet your
conscious mind is the one that says i
will think positive thoughts and i go
back to the data only five percent of
your life is coming from the conscious
mind so if you're only entertaining a
positive thought with your conscious
mind you're only contributing five
percent of that to your life 95 of your
life is still coming from the
subconscious and if the subconscious
doesn't hold those beliefs
then you're actually fighting yourself
and not likely to realize the expression
of a positive thought you have to wake
up to the reality folks that you're all
a bunch of weak and vulnerable people
when it comes to what's outside there
the sky is literally falling reports
from australia have come in that
everybody that walked outside their
survival shelter was literally crushed
by the sky as it came down upon them the
once beautiful and green hills of the
countryside have become a barren
wasteland not to mention a band of
unruly sorcerers and bewitched the land
there are even reports of animals taking
up arms walking on two legs be afraid
everyone this is something we could
never anticipate it is my job to keep
you informed of all the latest horrible
things going on out there i'm just
trying to protect you
i can't take any more of this i can't i
can't watch this anymore
no more water
no more food
how am i gonna survive in here
but i can't go out there
i can't survive in here
i can't survive out there
what am i gonna do
meet bruce lipton portrait of a man
paralyzed by fear
the lowly cellular biologist has been
hiding away in his survival shelter for
more days than he can count
and the apparent terror that reigns
outside the doors of his rusty
presents a limitless degree of terror in
his mind
however
there is one problem that takes center
stage on this inauspicious day
bruce has run out of food and water
the question of how to survive in a
state of chronic protection
lingers ever so greatly
what you are about to witness is a
strange sort of mortal combat between a
man
and his beliefs
in the twilight zone
you are entering a new reality of mind
unlock your potential with the key of
imagination
a realm of ever-changing perceptions
a world of quantum physics
beliefs and miracles
you have just crossed over
into the twilight zone
i've got no more water and i've got no
more food
i can't survive by staying in protection
in order to survive i have to go out
because i can grow on the outside and i
can't go out there
because there's so many scary things out
there that can threaten my life but
wait a minute
it was in quantum physics
yes quantum physics the most valid
science on this planet
ah
here it is
consciousness
is creating our life experiences
wow
i have to have a different consciousness
i can't be afraid because the stress
shuts off my immune system
and the stress shuts down my growth and
maintenance of my body i have to change
that consciousness i can't be in fear
i have to recognize how powerful i am
i am a co-creator of the world
i am strong
i am healthy i have to maintain this as
a way of life a belief system before i
go out there
but now that i'm aware
i no longer fear
going out there
[Music]
the world can often present us with a
frightening reality but sometimes the
fear we experience only exists in our
minds and now for bruce
fear only exists
in the twilight zone i don't care how
much knowledge is in your head if that
knowledge doesn't go into your
subconscious your life will stay exactly
the same as it was you can be the
brightest smartest academic and i say
fine did it change your life and the
answer is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming
and when you do that
you are all powerful in the creation of
your own life and so just walking around
and being able to recite all these
wonderful sayings and things that you
hear from all the wonderful teachers
that we have you say oh yes i remember
that that's a good quote that's a nice
quote oh that's a wonderful saying
it's irrelevant
until that saying becomes part of your
program because now you are living from
the saying and not talking about the
saying
and that was the total transformation of
a life that on an academic level was
successful on a personal level i don't
even want to talk about that
but it changed everything why
because instead of having to chase
after life
after this understanding
things came to me the light will bring
it to you
the only thing that's in your way of the
light is a block in your belief that
other people have put into your
programming
you take your knowledge that you have
make it your subconscious program and
you will manifest all of the wonderful
spiritual wisdom that you have heard
throughout your whole life is not words
now
it is life and behavior and that's our
destination everything you do in your
life you put out energy for
therefore start to review what you're
doing in your life because if you're
putting your energy into things you
cannot change in this world that is
exactly the same as writing a check and
just throwing away your money to the
outside because you get nothing back
from it so think about this very
interesting reality that you have this
energy checkbook and every time you use
energy you have to say is the use of
this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am i getting involved in a
in a political argument with people
where i'm going to use up all my energy
and will i have changed the world no
am i going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that i'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if i gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go beyond
survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear uh not
only are you just wasting your energy
but as in the biology belief
these negative thoughts these negative
stresses actually impair your immune
system and bring on disease itself
everybody's mind is like a tuning fork
because actually you can read brain
activity from outside your head with a
new thing called magnetoencephalograph
most people are familiar
electroencephalograph put wires on your
head and read your brain function the
new one magnetoencephalograph
encephalograph they put a probe out here
and they can read your brain function
from outside well it's a very important
point he says well if you're reading my
brain function from outside then what am
i doing i must be broadcasting my brain
function so all of us are like tuning
forks but if we're all out of tune
then there's a tendency for even a
tuning fork that tries to stay in tune
will be pushed out of tune by something
we call entrainment and the issue is
how can you survive in this world the
answer is you must essentially detach
yourself from this field around you not
be taken in by the stories not be buy
into the fear not to buy into the
threats on our existence to start to
recognize look we are creating these
lives if you buy other people's creation
then you manifest what they're creating
if you want what you want then you have
to not get engaged and the more
conscious you become
the less you are affected by the outside
fields and so this rising consciousness
that we're seeing is the evolution of
humanity to rise above the noise of the
background and recognize you are the
creator we also bought this and it's not
true
that there's somebody in the
subconscious meaning if my conscience
finds my subconscious engaging in some
behavior that's not supporting it and my
conscience is talking to myself and my
conscience saying bruce scott that was
stupid you could do better than that and
you're having this inner dialogue and
you're talking yourself and being very
upset about the fact that your behavior
seems to be out of control
who are you talking to
and i love this because the reality is
we're thinking we're talking to
ourselves and that's going to fix
something and what's it going to fix
well the program's in that subconscious
and here's where the problem lies
subconscious is a tape player there's
nobody in there
the the same exact truth holes in this
case get a tape player put a cassette
tape in it push play the program's
running and you don't like the
programming so here's what i want you to
do
go up and talk to the tape player go up
and talk to it suggest how to change the
program even tell it what you wanted to
play do do all this and then you realize
the program still plays it doesn't
change and then you get more upset
with yourself why because you've asked
this program to change it's not changing
yet then you get mad at yourself you
start yelling at yourself and now you're
berating yourself because you can't
control the tape then that doesn't work
and then of course the last step you
have to bring god in because obviously
you tried a change your life and it
didn't work so only god has to come in
here now and change the tape and and the
joke is
how much talking to a tape player does
it take before the tape changes the
answer is you can talk to your blue in
the face and it will not change it's not
that you can't change the tape
but you have to learn how to push the
record button
and then you can record new programs in
the subconscious but our old belief
system like conventional psychology
let's go over and find out why my life
is this way oh yeah my mom did this to
me and my dad did this and my friends
did this and now i make a whole list of
all the reasons why my life is this way
i'm very clear my conscious mind's got
oh god i can play that movie i can see
it
and the question is now that you're
aware
did it change the tape player the answer
is no
and that's why people get so upset they
they go through all of the psychology
counseling and stuff they know all the
reasons they still have the same life so
the issue is you want to make change
then you have to learn how to engage the
tape player in a record mode and not
just talk to it the thinking is not that
much in our control the brain is
operating as i said 95 from the
subconscious uh
but how did you actually then get
results in a relatively short space of
time well the the first thing how does a
subconscious learn and that's a very
critical thing
the conscious mind can learn from
reading a book so you the subconscious
mind can read a self-help book and you
go wow that sounds really great and then
you find you read the book but your life
is still the same and this turns out why
and the answer is because the
subconscious mind is more of a habit
mine things that you repeat over and
over again so the reality is if you can
stay conscious
be present
and when those negative thoughts come in
our head and psychologists tell us 70
percent of the time the thoughts that
are going through our head are negative
and redundant so the same negative
thoughts are going through if you could
stop those thoughts if you could hear
them as they come through like oh that's
not going to work or this will never
happen those kind of thoughts if you can
hear them and stop them consciously say
no
change the belief right there just give
the more positive thing
as you repeat this more frequently and
you keep repeating it the subconscious
mind begins to learn so as a habit if
you stay conscious and you have to work
at it and here's why people say well how
come only five percent from conscious
mind 95 for from subconscious because a
conscious mind can think into the future
and think into the past and solve
problems then think about it yourself
most of the time you're thinking about
something well if you're thinking you're
using the conscious mind well if you're
using the conscious mind for thinking
then who's running the show and the
answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
i'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is running in our mind we
start to realize that we're concerned
we're afraid we don't have enough i'm
not safe i'm not secure
and i say oh these thoughts i was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and i go yes this is really true
i said well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called
electroencephalograph and i could read
your brain activity and i go oh great i
can see this brain activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were
programmed to believe that our thoughts
are contained in our head
that if i have a thought it's just for
me not for anybody else it's inside and
it's working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not electro
encephalograph it's called magneto
encephalograph i say what's unique about
that i say read your brain i say yeah
but so does eeg i say yeah but eeg you
put the wires on the head and you get
the electrical activity conducted
through the skin from the brain and
that's what i'm reading and i said
what's different about emig
the probe is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i said well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i i don't see the
peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
i'll give you this most wonderful quote
i use it the other day in a lecture from
albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so definite definition the field is the
invisible energy right now you're in a
field there's cell phone broadcast
television television radio broadcasts
all kinds of information coming across
but guess what each one of you is a
broadcast in that field
the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives
and if enough of us collectively have an
energy that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief
we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share
thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head
but all around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively
creating reality with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough
it will end we all have approximately 50
trillion cells in our body and these
cells are all self-sufficient they have
their own memory they have their immune
immune system and in fact you're also
going to say that for 2.75 billion years
there was only one celled organisms
alive on the planet yeah
and the nature is
as the single cell evolved to be the
most intelligent it could be it ran into
a physical limitation because
intelligence is physically tied up with
the membrane or skin of the cell you can
only have so much membrane
so evolution apparently stopped it was
like two and a half billion years just a
single cell organism then i said well
how can you have more evolution the
answer is cells decided to come together
in community because when cells come
into community they share awareness so
there's more awareness with ten cells
than there is with one cell and there's
more awareness with a million or a
billion or a trillion so when you look
at a human being while we see ourselves
as single entities the truth is we are
made out of 50 trillion amoeba like
cells and so our body is this giant
community
and what makes it very exciting as you
mentioned is well in my own work with
cloning cells i can take a cell out of
your body and it can live outside of you
why it has its own intelligence it has
essentially every function in your body
is present in a cell so my
seven-year-old vision manifests to be
true when i got older to realize cells
are miniature people and then you say
well what about happens in the human
body and i go this is where the issue
comes in is because you have 50 trillion
cells living in community but your mind
is the government
when a government works in harmony with
the people
then the people thrive and the community
is is in good health and grows but when
a government is not really supportive or
not working in in harmony with a
community then the government can cause
the
the nature of that community to fall
apart and even lead to to to the end of
the community well that's what we're
finding out our mind is the government
and when we
entertain harmony and and the right
living and balance with nature and with
each other then we provide our 50
trillion cells with very life-supporting
information and chemistry so harmony
means
giving the body
good food yes not being stressed out
absolutely living in a in a happy
environment yes
basically it says uh it's as i said when
i had my petri dish of cells if i put it
from a healthy environment to a bad
environment the cells got sick but you
didn't have to give them drugs
but all you did is take the the dish
from the bad environment and put it in a
good environment and the joke which i
like to tell people is
well this happens in a plastic petri
dish but guess what we are skin-covered
petri dishes underneath our skin
is 50 trillion cells living in a dish
and the culture medium is the blood and
so when i change the culture medium to
plastic dish i change the fate of the
cells and i say well then what controls
the culture medium my blood the
chemistry and the answer is
my thoughts influence my brain and the
brain releases chemistry that matches my
thoughts so when i'm in stress or i'm
afraid of the world i release different
chemistry into the blood than if i open
up my eyes and i find myself in love i
release completely different chemistry
and it's like well
all i have to ask an individual is how
do you feel when you're in total love or
how do you feel when you're in fear and
answers well i feel totally different i
guess what all the cells are bathed in
that chemistry and so the the feeling of
love produces totally different
chemistry in the blood chemistry that
supports growth and healing of the body
and supports the immune system and in
contrast
when we perceive reasons to be afraid
and we release stress hormones into our
body
we actually shut off the growth
mechanisms and the immune system to
serve to save the energy why because if
you believe you're going to have to run
from that lion
you want all the energy available to run
from a line so when a person is in
stress
they allocate their energy reserves for
fight or flight
but take it at the expense of the health
of the system the immune part of the
system and so the more stress you're
under the more bad chemistry in a sense
of not supporting you you that you
experience
and and it's a very important point
in our evolution stress or fear was not
the main stay of life the mainstay of
life was to be happy and live in the
harmony of the environment
every now and then a saber-toothed tiger
would come okay now it's time to be
stressed out now it's time to run but
the point is once you escape from the
sabretooth tiger in the old days then
it's like oh back to health and harmony
and i say what about today's world
today's world is 24 7 run from the tiger
and this is not biologically sustainable
because
the chemistry of protection
contrasts with the chemistry of growth
[Music]
i'm mad as heck but i will take it
anymore
[Music]
and then you can look at it oh
oh
i reckon i'm good on that okay
great i don't know thank you
[Music]
up up and away
[Music]
welcome to funk meister studios where
all the magic happens
[Music]
hello
doc yeah it's marty where are you
oh
okay yeah yeah i'll be right there
[Music]
doc
doc
doc where are you
hey doc let me in it's pouring rain out
here just wait just wait two more
seconds
[Music]
oh
oh
no
oh
marty
marty marty we gotta get back to the
future doc what what happened to the
delorean well i couldn't keep up with
the payments during the pandemic but hey
this is a good baby
[Music]
[Applause]
all right all right
marty marty we have to go back to the
future right now doc
the future seems very uncertain i don't
think we should be going to the future
right now you're not thinking fourth
dimensionally get in the car i'll
explain it to you when we get there all
right
[Music]
so
whoa
doc
where are we when are we
marty just look at the inborn monitor
down there and what you can see is we
are in between time we're moving from an
old civilization and we're moving
through time into the future of a new
civilization
wow this looks pretty chaotic and random
is that normal well actually it's not
random and you're right it is chaotic
because chaotic has pattern even though
you can't see it and if you want to know
what the pattern is look the old
civilization is coming down and as it's
coming down the pieces are forming a new
civilization that is rising up and we
are now in the middle so it's not random
so this is all just a big illusion well
it is an illusion because once you think
the world is made out of matter and
energy that's a false understanding but
now quantum physics revealed there is no
separation of matter and energy atoms
which make up matter are energy so
everything is an illusion
reality is an illusion
albeit a persistent one
so you're telling me that the future
changes depending on the field that we
have intentions for well absolutely the
reason is this because as the planet
moves through the solar system in the
universe the energy surrounding this
planet changes that's the field and when
the field changes the matter changes so
we are in a process of evolution moving
from an old structure into a new
sustainable world to understand what i'm
talking about marty look at the inboard
monitor there i can show you about the
science called cymatics that's the
science of how vibration and energy and
field shapes matter
as you can see how it works you sprinkle
particles on a metal plate and then when
you play a vibration and energy field
through that plate the vibration causes
the particles to jump around and form a
pattern but when you change the
vibration the old pattern falls apart
and simultaneously a new pattern is
emerging this is exactly where we are
today and planet earth
wow doc that is sick
sick marty i don't know what you kids
are talking about everything is safe no
we're moving into the future where
everything is health and harmony and
love
hold on marty
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some incredible motivation from joe
dispenza check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there oh i would ask them to take out a
piece of paper and write down every
thought
that they've been thinking that standing
in the way between their future and and
where they are